your observer columns over kind of the
last five years yes yeah and the columns
kind of covered you know things that are
going on in the news and in our culture
and in our society and it's one of the
things you pick up on is what's happened
to facts that facts aren't what they
once were
yeah facts we're talking about the
defunct way of sending messages that's
the thing the Internet has happened to
both forms of fact both faxes and fact
scene - yeah because now essentially you
can't tell truth from from lies they
both look perfectly nicely typeset
they're both on websites you people are
loads of people endlessly saying how
make mainstream media is all lies it's
not all lies is it I mean in fact
there's a lot more recourse if there is
a specific lie in mainstream media than
there is on a random website that
someone's just put up there but people
are going around saying no mainstream
media is all lies and that is
and the fact that people think that is
extremely worrying but it's one of the
other terrible effects of the internet
that we that the truth you know it is
out there but it may never again be
discerned but also but you seem to be
going backwards like you talked with a
book about how we now have to listen to
people saying the earth is flat yeah yes
that's that one of the pieces in there
is about the the new the new Flat Earth
international conference it isn't a
conference from the 14th century this is
a conference that started I think in
2017 and it is a growing thing and
that's because people are so contrarian
people are so willing to believe
unsubstantiated things that have
websites that they are now going back on
the conclusion we have all rightly drawn
about the shape of the planet
people are sort of going and by people I
mean idiots questioning person so why am
I going to go along with this idea that
the world is round what tell you why
because people went up in a rocket out
of a window and took a bloody photo
[Applause]
[Music]
you